welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedian and we
find it at the group to be classy yeah
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at antodi's basement she's upstairs
glued to the television watching the ufo
hearings okay yeah she says she hooked
up with an alien a couple years ago
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me
that's the first time you ever got a
guest i think
i can imagine it
i saw her she was pretty engrossed up
there it was just a guy from sweden he's
just dead
back to stinkin
my co-host as i said at 2-4 is the ceo
the founder of argue garbage
international businessman not to be
trifled in the boardroom or the boudoir
give it up for kj kevin james ryan
what's up you got my haircut you got my
number today big man what's up everybody
uh thanks as always make sure you review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube as you know those numbers are
true cooking then the greatest website
of all time patreon.com i'll show you
garbage time if you get episodes ayg
episodes hard feelings live streams and
the 10 000 spin should be on there by
the time this airs check it the [ __ ] out
damn you read that as fast as like those
disclaimers on a
pfizer commercial i'm contractually
obligated to mention the greatest
website of all time patreon.com we may
cause liver damage
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the [ __ ]
magic man he's the best in the biz we
love them you love them give it up for
t-bone mcbuttons
toby thomas edward mcmullen what's up
dude
three of those names were wrong
this is gonna be a hot one dude we got
one of the best in the biz baby we did i
said in the intro your favorite comedian
and it wasn't a mistake i said it on
purpose because he's one of our absolute
[ __ ] favorites games we got him back
here again his family at this point but
a great advocate of us he's a [ __ ]
good good man and he is going to be in
brooklyn new york june 11th and 12th
doing a little tapey wait be 11th is
sold out get tickets for the 12th ari
shafir.com ladies and gentlemen the one
the only
ari shafir all right thank you
thank you thank you for coming up your
screen a computer recorder for this i
appreciate it the nsa will not know
about this until it's out yeah no way
yeah not getting caught i want to you
know we typically ask how you're doing
and stuff like that i just met him
downstairs in the lobby breaking the
fourth wall
he tried to edit the kitchen of your
mom's
uh he tried to end he got stopped
entering the building because he tried
to enter without his shirt on it
i was walking sun's out guns out loud
the land sun's out guns out who do you
[ __ ] jeff's piccoli
and i'm walking by again this guy
wouldn't let me in i'm like why is it i
have a shirt on i'm like yeah that makes
sense he's like hey he's like where are
you going i'm like uh second floor he's
like which uh which uh which which
office i'm like i don't know tom it's
like sign in i'm like what you're not
making anybody else excited i can't
write or read you look homeless to begin
with you can't be walking around with no
shirt on
that i didn't think of that yeah
i have misshapen nips through their
honeymoon
all you need is a hospital bracelet
everybody stay the [ __ ] away from you
yikes
i'm here to see the president
oh
i'm not gonna hurt him or anything he
was like do you believe this guy really
questioned me trying to enter an office
building with no clue i almost said
something on the way and i'm like see i
know people when you guys came back i'm
like he's with me it's all right we
barely get in are you kidding me
that's good stuff you're a big shirt off
guy sun's out
which there two four
call of a homer as it would be in
judaism skunks out guns out yeah he's a
big gun's out guy this he's like if you
see my guns out you don't even have to
look up the sun you don't have to look
at the weather app the sun is out
i got bobby kelly's kid doing it too
he's always with the shirt off and he's
like sunshine
dude already told me yeah
has there been any place that you have
decided to leave because they would not
let you keep your guns out i got thrown
out of key foods once uh dude that's bad
yeah it's the lowest level that's
supermarket who gets thrown out of the
key foods yeah
i've seen goats in there
what the [ __ ] man i was getting set for
barbie july 4th barbecue and i was in
there i was like sons i mean you know
guns were out and i went in i was i
think i was with gomez louis gomez uh
lewis nominal named gomez and i uh and i
went and eventually the guy was like sir
no
it wasn't even like you have to it's
like obviously not
it's like it's not america anymore like
yeah and uh city fields i got told to
put my shirt on i was like i know
baseball game how long has this been a
rule and he goes i've worked here since
74. it's always been a rule it's not
nascar yeah but not like back in the day
you could i feel like that was probably
more of a thing well when there was
riots at yankee stadium yeah
they were a little loose people smoking
cigs in the stands and [ __ ] families
here not trying to sell corporate
tickets i went to a city uh uh uh
commission not commission
family no no the one in chicago the real
team in chicago the white sox no the
other one the cubbies
and i was like ask the guy we're sitting
the bleachers and i was like hey i can't
take my shirt off here right he goes why
would you not be able to take your shirt
off i'm like [ __ ] what yeah here we
go goddamn uppity mets
i think they're better than us
hey we can take our balls out out here
right what's the deal
which you used to do a lot as well you
were a big ball guy yeah we had this
thing we did at the comedy store called
cockings uh where you would get he's
nuts yeah you would get a distractor
someone distract her so like uh so you'd
come in it should be like hey uh what's
toby's shirt you go over there look at
his shirt and i just take my balls and i
just rest him on your hand oh yeah and
so he's got a bad bag too
he went i was a bad man
i can't reach you the word on the street
it's a tough hang
it's like a wet bag of groceries
yikes i got a bad sack too oh yeah big
balls low hangers low hangers not good
you got uneven uh yeah the right side
goes down a little more i want to always
hurt you lower yeah yeah that's where
yeah i'm uh do you hit the water in the
toilet bowl sometimes on the public
toilet it's those
shallow ones yeah and you gotta hold now
i know you gotta throw them over your
shoulder
you gotta you gotta hold them up yeah
like a like a christian hurting himself
for past sins
yeah that's bad when you get the water
touches like damn it when the water's
warm that worries me more when it's cold
for some reason sometimes public toilets
the water is warm this i don't know if
you drink it out of it
because the balls can feel it yeah yeah
it's like a [ __ ] dolphin sonar down
yeah it should show you everything you
want to know it's like a super computer
speaking of bath we have we've talked we
haven't talked about this in a while i
don't think we ever talked about it with
you
how do you if you're you know if you're
uh taking a dump in public yeah which i
feel like you don't have any qualms with
you'll go anywhere for the most part
dude i was on i don't want to say whose
name because they don't want to seem
uppity but i was on a private jet with a
comedian he doesn't want people knowing
he takes private jets which is what
he should do
but anyway i was like so you can just
go to the bathroom like the door open
like i mean you could and i'm like and i
just waited till takeoff and then oh
nice [ __ ] with the door open back
defecation on a plane man that's living
were you invited back i was not yeah
dude if i was spending if i was spending
private jet money and you [ __ ] in there
with the door did it stink up the whole
cabin i hope i don't know
well you [ __ ] on a normal plane
i have done it twice ever really it's so
awful it's not great and so i'm [ __ ]
i take a while you know what i got my
shirt off the usual deal
this [ __ ] stewardess comes in tells
me i can't have my shirt off knocking
the door six seven minutes in whatever
normal time i was going as fast as i
could knocking on the door i was like um
in here like i mean like you see the
thing is already listed there's no
there's no doors yeah there's nothing in
here
click open
she [ __ ] went i was like hey what the
[ __ ] i thought i lost it and she was
like well i thought the door was locked
for so long i was like i'm taking a dump
and i got i was like what was it she was
in there a long time like yeah dumps
take a while
couple knocks before you just open it to
the world a couple i could have been
[ __ ] in here
[Laughter]
that's so embarrassing this is a flight
attendant did this yeah how long was the
flight
it would be weird that i could yeah
i was flying to long island chicago
uh i couldn't wait i couldn't wait but
how do you clean a public toilet seat
uh beforehand yeah i was like
well i get my plunger yeah yeah cleaning
his job i don't know what to tell you
full wipe down on the are we talking
about the break
the break in the toilet in the middle no
no don't know how that is it doesn't go
all the way around it's gonna go like
this goes like that stops in the middle
stops in the middle you touch that no
take a
i wipe that because there's typically a
lot of pee on that i don't want i don't
want someone else's pee on my wings oh
so you gotta watch the top of that which
i'll lift up go under a little bit wipe
the inside
balls and dick might touch at least
inside the front and then the toll
different one hole with water whole seat
where'd you get the water sick
smart yeah why don't you give him your
run down real quick i do something
similar
just well documented on this broadcast
uh i do something similar but i get the
water from
boots
from the toilet
come on dude no
no push it a couple of times
and then just dab a little bit of water
and give it to the bowl yeah man there's
a like [ __ ] seven thousand people
have [ __ ] in there as soon as it comes
in it's touch it's instantly
it's instantly wrong again the water is
the the water in your
uh bathroom at home has also touched a
million different uh people's
butt holes i don't use that water to
wipe it down
the sink is right there oh i apologize
i'd rather i'll spit on it like i get if
a publix is a sink's not right there uh
uh if you're in a stall person yeah yeah
yeah spit on it wipe it down like you're
[ __ ] in prison yeah i respect that
more than toilet bowl water or dry
before toilet water reinfecting it i
know that's it now i need to wipe it
down again i assume that water's clean
oh you're crazy that's the wrong
assumption if i wipe it down and i throw
you throw that thing in the toilet if a
drop comes back out i'm like rewind
start over that's a reward the whole
thing again gotta do the whole thing
again all right i'm working on it
i'll try it
i don't believe yous
[Laughter]
throw a graphic in there
that made me think of something have you
ever been thrown out of anywhere out of
a bathroom no
no just in general well key foods the
key food other than that without the
shirt that's a good question let me toss
out of a restaurant have you guys at
bars in bars
like you know young like yeah drink it
too much you ever just try to do the 21
drinks for your 21st birthday yeah i
didn't make it so no one makes it yeah
blacked out more specifically have you
ever been banned for life from someone
oh that's pretty good you got real
banned for life face like i shoplifted a
lot and i really wanted my life
principles too you shoplift a lot yeah
oh yeah so i'm i'm worried that one day
i'm going to walk into a whole foods
7-eleven with the picture up like this
is a thief and i'm like turn around nope
good looking guy yeah they got my
friend's aunt on it where they were like
uh they were like she was young but like
they were like hey you stole you forgot
to pay for some of your things last time
oh my god i'm so sorry it's a mistake i
was just holding i didn't realize like
we've seen you do it eight times right
yeah that's impact when was the last
time you stole
definitely this week i don't know this
week for sure us constantly what'd you
steal
little things
um i don't even know it happens so much
it's like it's like children what are we
groceries uh uh well you just go in and
take something and walk out where you
withhold as you pay for the rest as you
pay you withhold that's an easy one uh
anytime you see anything like if i'm uh
if i'm in a sporting goods store and i'm
tossing around football i see if i want
to toss it around and then i realize
like hey no one's even looking at me
right now he walks out with a golf club
and i could and i go for a hail mary out
the front door no because you're like if
you're not trying to hide it if you're
just like this you know like whatever
and then if they if they catch you on
the way out go oh my god i didn't even
not realize i was in the [ __ ] because
clearly i would have tried to hide it
and then like i saw i was just walking
around with it like yeah yeah yeah yeah
sarah please put that surfboard back
right right right it's in a full wetsuit
would give me an idea a little i won't
steal from mom and pops yeah that yeah
okay yeah foods i'm sure you [ __ ] go
ham in there yeah for sure unless it's
the one i have to go back to a lot and
then i'm like this can be embarrassing
and it'll really affect my life you're
not sliding meat down like the front of
your shirt or anything like that are you
doing like salmon the other day what you
stole salmon yeah nice rust salmon
thirty dollars
i cooked it up fresh tastes better it's
got a lot of spice on it what where'd
you put it uh um
so did you go to the guy at the at the
airport constantly airport that's a big
comic thing comics also
you put it on they're not looking it's
they're not going to die for you this
isn't their product they're working
there
everybody relax give me the neck pillow
nobody gets it
on your roller bag you put it on there
you shop around for other stuff buy some
nuts
get out of there or don't buy the nuts
you got to scope it do the nuts if
they're staring at you
don't sure the salmon did you walk up to
the guy at the seafood counter and say
hey give me a give me a pound of this
really and you stole it yeah dude ah man
you did that to the seafood guy
i thought the whole foods was still was
we're talking about the discount hole
yeah give me the whole
discount you got the money while caught
what if you got
and freshly stolen
okay let's talk about indochino
indochino indochino indochine indochina
i'm sure throughout your history you've
been in some situations where you showed
up dressed like a bozo most of the time
i've dressed like a bozo because i don't
know what to buy where to buy it what to
wear we talk about that on the show all
the time well how would you like to have
a place where you could get
nice blazers custom shirts custom suits
the whole nine yards so that way when
you show up to your cousin's christening
or your nephew's wedding you don't like
a complete loser sure would i feel
great confident enjoyed a big day
without falling over my clothes i think
i would over there
at indochino let's go they sent us some
clothes i call them my fancy clothes i
walk around strutting my stuff sometimes
shirt on sometimes shirt off maybe just
the pants i got a nice tie that i enjoy
show off the derriere um
it's fantastic guys it takes the
guesswork out all this stuff listen
everybody listens most of us are bozos
we don't know what we're doing if you
got something coming up this summer or a
wedding or whatever you don't gotta
think about it peep out in docino it'll
square you up bada bing bada boom have
you lookin like i don't know a bajillion
dollars there you go uh every suit is
made to your exact measurements you can
customize every detail create a suit
that fits uh you your style perfectly
with options for fabrics lapel shape
custom monograms statement linings and
more big statement lines go big lapels
they're coming back yeah real peshy
style yeah um the best part enducino
suits start at just 4.99
uh and shirts at 79 79 dollars inducing
offer also offers completely custom
fitted shirts casual wear and more get a
wardrobe personalize your style without
spending a fortune
if you got a big day coming up getting
the perfect look is no big deal with
indochino get 50 off any purchase of
3.99 or more that's cold hard cash we're
talking about over here not presented
50 bucks off any purchase of 3.99 or
more using promo code garbage at
indonesia.com that's 50 off i'll
purchase 3.99 at i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot com probably go garbage out back to
the show
yeah create diversions
i was it i was at oktoberfest i won one
of those big bear steins and they have
people that's obviously what you're
gonna steal so they have people like no
no no me and my brother were just there
like we want these [ __ ] beer steins
so we threw a pipe bomb in the parking
lot
[Laughter]
called him anti-semitic and got
yeah
um and then it was um
yeah there was a fight broke out the
security guards were like no no no and
just [ __ ] take off
jesus
yeah it's wild what if you got caught
right it's on tmz ari shafir caught
steel
that would be an improvement from the
last time it was on tmz yeah yeah yeah
yeah true true
that'd be cooler moving into petty crime
i towed it down
[Laughter]
this week you're stealing i'm sure it's
like it's a non-stop thing
never been caught huh
not since i was like in high school or
something and even then my sister
interrupted this she got the phone call
hey uh your son's stuff and she was like
i will talk to him
oh i'm like no i didn't i tried to deny
it she goes you didn't steal a pair of
sunglasses i was like no you think i
just guessed that you're wearing it
you're wearing them yeah with a tag
still on it
where'd you get those oakleys are you
sit
that's a good sister though have you
ever ran out on a check
from a restaurant no i've wanted to but
no and it's always like it's so it's
just like dining ditch but no way yeah
yeah i can't do that can't do that yeah
they will track you down yeah cause
that's happened to me that happened to
me on st patrick's day also really and i
[ __ ] tracked the guy the guy ran out
[ __ ] ran down the street i went the
other way dropped everything
i was like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm going
get this guy you're uninvolved huh it's
not your restaurant no he was working
you were right i was waiting tables yeah
i wasn't just this one trying to be here
it wasn't this saint patty's day oh yeah
no no
it was like two weeks ago yeah i was
like damn dude you're really getting
money what am i captain america
hold on ma'am get my ass kicked does it
come out of your check when somebody
bails on a check that's why he always
has a rumor it could but it's not even
that it's the [ __ ] i don't want to be
[ __ ] doing this anyway you think
you're [ __ ] better than me you're
acting like a [ __ ] [ __ ] then you
[ __ ] run out on me because it
happened to me years before this it was
like the the the nolan ryan incident the
[ __ ] somebody charged the mound on me
years before that i ran after them
they're like no we left it on the
counter and i went back and it wasn't
there and i [ __ ] up you fell for that
fell for it why who runs out of a
restaurant after they paid the bill i
was new in the industry i don't know
what to tell the sellers like we paid
like where's your stamp and you just
stand yeah but this guy i wasn't letting
go he wore it he was wearing a kilt too
and i [ __ ] saw that
i closed it like no you didn't i saw you
then you're like it's so embarrassing i
saw a guy shoplifting from a [ __ ] mom
and pop odega i was coming and i go
there all the time and i was coming in
they grabbed this guy and he's like let
go of me whatever well-dressed like not
poor you know like middle-class guy
28 30 something like that and he's like
and they tried commiserating with me
he's like dude and he goes i have this
you don't even sell this big back at
eminem's like what about the doritos
what about the whatever yeah and he
starts commiserating with me he's like
they just accused me for no reason i was
like hey man there's zero chance that
you're just gonna accuse a random person
of shopping shoplifting yeah it's like
just give it back and he goes i didn't
steal anything i'm like hey man you got
caught i get it but once you've got one
right now don't take it just sorry opens
up his jacket
you're gonna blow it for both of us man
but it's like if you get caught and you
still do it that's that's the same as
just shoving them over and taking a
shoplifting is a quiet crime sure you're
caught you should be embarrassed and say
i'm so sorry and walk out and never show
your face again you don't say i didn't
do it you're caught have some respect
for the game
[Music]
there's a code shoplifters live but he's
just like you just not as good
you could that could be you getting
jacked up by some mom and pop we talked
about it she's like we see the [ __ ]
you go around the corner we see you
hanging out there where there's only
apples for [ __ ] 10 minutes and come
back we're watching you do you ever see
that guy
they got big on youtube and like
instagram and stuff the guy the gas
station guy i [ __ ] love him he's it's
like a young kid i don't even know if
his family is like owns the i think
they're in cleveland and he people come
in and steal [ __ ] everything and dude
he's got a he's like a master in
behavior yeah oh dude he [ __ ] and
then he he dubs it over it's fantastic
look up at the camera they're hanging
out here they're moving around there and
they'll come up and pay and they'll be
like oh do you want to get those
skittles out of your pocket and what the
[ __ ] i brought these or
whatever it's great i steal so much you
know how they say like if you cheat on
your wife or girlfriend or boyfriend or
husband then then um
you start thinking they're cheating
you know that's like a standard yeah so
now whenever i go into a store with like
an unopened water or something like that
i'd be like hey before i go i bought i
already have this they're like yeah
whatever no no not whatever yeah i would
think i told him sure yeah of course
yeah yeah i thought he just stole this
from the store down the street yeah it's
mine now though it's mine i thought you
meant you thought people were stealing
from you
oh whole foods broke into my house i'm
telling you where is that produce here
the [ __ ] fish guy came back that
seafood guys looking for me
beautiful all right let's get into some
cues some patreon questions guys news
from mr shafir peaches the
brooklyn new york june 11th until
brooklyn guys come out you live in new
york area come out see the guys grandma
let's go special and it's my best one
yeah oh yeah it's the one i worked on
the hardest i didn't have any like
storytelling show editing distracting me
it was just like what would happen to
that
[Laughter]
guys we're having fun having a good time
that would have been great if you would
have knocked down oh my god if i just
lost hey the clip alone i'm on air
steals the pringles
yeah exactly
[Laughter]
did you ever steal toys or anything like
that when you were a kid from your other
friends kid oh when i was yeah
these kids oh my nephew's playstation
huh they can't fight back they're weak
they think i'm an adult so it's like
doesn't make sense to them out the door
um uncle larry have you seen our dog no
i have not yeah i stole a baseball card
from this guy george brett rookie card i
still feel bad about it sort of
still have the card still have it at my
parents house no no long gone but i
should go back and get it just give it
back to him now that the bottom has
dropped out of the market
now that it's worthless you can have it
it was like 75 bucks back then and then
when it's like 200 now it's probably
like 80 cents i'm like oh hey man i'm
making it up that's [ __ ] yeah
it's good
as you know when you sign up for the
patreon get your questions read on the
air now if you don't know how to sign up
you just go over to patreon.com and then
you enter from there's a search bar and
put ru garbage three words and that'll
bring up the most important patreon
podcast of all time
obama had a patreon podcast that he did
with donald trump for a while that was
less important than this yes that's
right didn't obama have a podcast he did
they spotify didn't renew it they were
like too boring billy joel
billy joel no bree springsteen
it might have been springsteen it might
have been he had one with a famous guy i
was gary busey i think
shout out to the views obama and busy
good [ __ ] all right let's lock into some
cues here let's do it yeah it was bruce
[ __ ] brinkstein wow really yeah what
does everyone talk about yeah what are
they talking about
i heard you like doing drone strikes
i was operating i struck my ptsd for my
dad
shout out to the boss we're not being
disrespectful you ever been to new
jersey
[Laughter]
have you ever had him on here you should
ask him like when's the last time we
were actually in new jersey
next question i'm out he just got she
just got arrested for drinking and
driving didn't you nice dude still
bringing it
yeah man jersey didn't you imagine the
[ __ ] truth how imagine how [ __ ] up
you got to be to get pulled over by a
state trooper in jersey and arrested
yeah it's like what's standard here yeah
that guy's getting ostracized at the
[ __ ] troop i could tell you that
can't be trusted you're not you're
bringing in the [ __ ]
what that's the boss
are you kidding me i sign your paychecks
[ __ ]
i'm gonna ask you crap i'm not gonna ask
you have you ever i'm gonna because it's
obvious
i'm gonna ask you when's the last time
you drove drunk boom boom boom
high school
maybe once and i regretted it to this
day
never once because i never got my
license loophole fair loophole that's a
good jew loophole we'll cover that in
more an aria should hurt jew taping june
12th and june 11th
brooklyn
[Laughter]
um i haven't drove drunk in a while i
i really
as a young as a youngster
a lot too much
um he's talking 12 13
to the point where i i like as i got
older and you mature more you don't
realize you think you're
unstoppable yeah exactly
and uh
probably
early 20s was probably the last time i
really got
became a [ __ ] i got like really scared
of it or anything no i was just like
i've made it this i'm like this is my
friend started getting dui's and stuff
like that
[ __ ] out man my dad instilled that's
on us very very hard
never [ __ ] do that right yeah he's
like if you ever get a [ __ ] dui i'll
beat this [ __ ] out nine not so much uh
you got one no no i never got one but
i'm just saying we we also we will young
fellas out there that will just do the
[ __ ] up don't do it it's like 15 grand
it cost you yeah
and then if you get a second one you're
that's it you can't drive you know how
much that [ __ ] your life less in new
york than other places but like my dad
never said it because it was like
assumed like what yeah what do you what
are you plus everybody in the circle
knows about it moms are talking in the
paper for
you become the [ __ ] bozo
don't do it my buddy did get my buddy
had two and uh he had to have the
breathalyzer installed wow wow to start
it up to start it up and then every like
15 minutes you had to blow into it as
well
just like that's on the road that's on
the road at all times yeah it's quite
it's crazy in the burbs it's wild you
would think cops would just sit outside
bars and just snag people left and right
yeah i think beach towns are just like
eh
it happens yeah it's a little yeah
so they make their money though yeah but
like off season and like shelter island
you know they're like it's your locals
yeah i assume i don't know or shelter
island just like deep deep long island
well oh i know it's shelter island yeah
but it's like the local once the tourist
i thought i was talking about shutter
island
you know leonardo dicaprio
yeah shelter island's different it's all
locals and yeah
yeah yeah it's a good vibes that's a key
west i imagine i really
everybody's got a couple in them it's
like don't push it yeah yeah a couple in
them it's like the normal stance but
like a couple in them was the 80s and
90s that's why i started saying buzz
driving is drunk driving remember that
campaign that came out big but then
you're like well then what's drunk
driving then what if i'm drunk then what
is that is that buzz driving no it's
different shut up it's different
all these campaigns they're like don't
tell the whole [ __ ] story if you
don't tell everybody the whole story
then it's like it's like a condom or a
baby like or
pull out and throw it on our [ __ ]
tits and not have a baby don't don't act
like that's not an option
getting the campaign slogan yeah this
guy's nuts yeah it's it's it's it's uh
it's put your shirt back on
the sixth trainer six feet under like no
no it's the likelihood goes up but come
on sure sure
anyway don't drive drunk don't drive
drunk kids yes don't do whatever you
want make sure you don't have your shirt
on all right
they were going through a
what's it called checkpoint a
dui checkpoint no no no no
jersey told whatever and we're we're
coming back from woodstock adopted there
and we're but you know you get the
ticket you have to give it back to them
this is pre-coveted you have to give
back to them i see how far you went then
that's how much they charge you and so
we went we're like where's that ticket
like you can't find it and you never got
out of your car which i can't find and
the lady's like all right i'm like i'm
sorry miss i can't find the ticket she
goes but you got it like a few exits ago
i know i know she's like where are you
coming from and we're just like both
stoned out of our minds and she's like
where are you coming from we're like
woodstock
and she's like
i believe you
smoke billowing out of the window
i'm pulled over i can't pull over any
farther
oh
mr shaffer
that's funny as [ __ ] all right guys some
questions
um this is from will
have you or anyone in your family called
it a laptop instead of laptop
i
ninety percent of the time i say laptop
no yeah i just say
like laboratory yeah i assume
back in the day i assumed that's what
scientists use to do their research oh
in a lab laptop like why are they called
top it's on top of the lat like you're
in the lab it's on top of the i don't
know man i'm clearly wrong all right so
it would be lab desktop
sure
no
it would be laptop
well how would it go would you do it
this conversation i've ever had
no you're right yeah it'd be lab tech or
lab computer if you're if it's about a
lab yeah
it wouldn't be on top of the lab he's
right right yeah like you're doing it on
the roof the top negates the lab
but not the lap yeah so i didn't put a
lot of thought in conclusion you're
stupid oh yeah for sure
i've never called her that no laptop
laptop yeah my mom once said i was like
upstairs she was using computer early
and i was just like where's that file
like it's in the desktop you know i
already know that's pulling through i'm
like it's right there there's nothing on
your you're so neat
six things on there so i could buy the
stapler i'm like oh jesus
let me help you my mother refers to our
laptop our tablet no matter what it is
she calls it the ipad door she'll call
it she'll call the she'll she'll say go
get the ipad and i'm like you don't have
an ipad just anything the one the the
laptop she calls it an ipad oh i can see
another brand of of tablets calling in
an ipad but not right now that's all
chef that's the technology she knows and
that's the technology she calls it i
think this was the first all you garbage
question that i passed
in three or four three episodes yeah
yeah so you know what i did just see
that was kind of it was you were the
first one
the clip came somebody tagged us in the
club as you were used to microwave eggs
yeah that's what i always talk about
that's wild man that used to no no i had
done it it wasn't like that was my thing
for a period of time whether it was once
or twice you did it
all right so but don't say you used to
do it you have
you once did it it's different than you
used to do it do you steal the eggs too
do you ever steal eggs that's too cheap
that's what you pay for it yeah that's
like a good time
hey i'm only getting a dozen yeah yeah
twelve fillets in here or you try to
open up one that's a guy open up on it
in between that like the right in
between put another egg close it up oh
my god who's stealing one egg yeah it's
for ten cents what are you doing why
would you risk that when you go buy eggs
what do you have carton eggs and two
tubes you're buying like just the cheapo
ones of 1.99 not anymore because i spent
a a month in um in edinburgh a few times
but you guys should do at some point uh
it's a comedian's [ __ ] rite a passage
and the eggs there it's so natural the
yolks are this orange just deep orange i
love that and then they're not
refrigerated
yeah they don't they don't wash them off
so they just might remember to leave
them on top like hey they're gonna go
bad like what do you mean why did i go
bad that's the first time you see that
it blows your [ __ ] mind it's because
they don't treat them with something
they don't spro we spray ours with
something they don't wash off the door
sound
idiot i was like that was a good shuffle
yeah um
yeah and we wash ours off because they
look better but then they have to get
refrigerated yeah we spray them with
some chemical that then they have to be
refrigerated they bleach them
yeah they bleach eggs to sell sell
better so now you go for the fancy ones
yeah so i'll go for organic or like farm
raised because i'm like why are these
yellows that makes orange and like i
looked into it and i just felt healthier
eating them they're cleaner they feel
cleaner it costs a little more they cost
like 50 cents an egg instead of like 10
cents an egg but like that's 50 cents an
egg i thought the food in scotland
everybody stayed away from i wouldn't
trust the highest
haggis that's like a pig's [ __ ] or
something right dude i ate [ __ ] it's
it's
like you bury it in the ground it's like
isn't it crazy you don't bake it in the
head it's it's true it's like it's like
intestine they shove full of like uh
it's delicious it's delicious though i'm
so good it's so good i went into it like
a lot of foods i'll go into trying like
i'll try this so i can say i had it i'm
not gonna enjoy it those un uh developed
eggs in uh like cambodia and um in the
philippines you know a little baby fetus
egg shut up
and i'm like i'm gonna i hate this and i
did it's not it's it's whatever but
there's something there's a chicken oh
yeah dude fetus
the bones aren't even congealed yet so
like
yeah so it's like
it's like the the texture of like your
inside dude stop stop we get it stop
explaining it oh that that that's what
it was like it's like this one right
here it pulls on out when you slurp up
that beak oh that beak is a texture of a
human nose that's what i'm looking for
yeah how's the nose tonight
yikes have you ever eaten dog
uh i think by accident once oh i was in
uh he's timor and uh and somebody told
me i was like what is what's what kind
of meat is this they have these wall
rooms it's like it's like it's it's kind
of like a pizza where you could like
point to the different like form of that
slice and it's like that with different
meats like what is that and like duck
i'm like duck like no duck i mean you
know where it's going sure then i'm like
and they called rw sometimes too and
then eventually i was like oh and i
probably would have had it if it wasn't
like left out you know just like sitting
yeah just sitting i'm like that's not
the way i'm going to have
dog but then another thing i was like
soup and they were like it's all the
meats and i'm like [ __ ]
probably dog was in
there hmm and you're a dog owner i mean
it was before i was a dog owner
i'd still have it you gotta try it
never this guy's nuts puppy doggy now i
would have to be pretty drunk and
driving but i think i could do it
i would kill everybody in that
restaurant
why ever eaten dog you have a cow brain
no there was a place called animal and
on melrose and it was most no it was one
of those up and down streets connected
to melrose and they had
yeah how about a turkey sandwich bro
did you grab a slice of pizza don't you
aren't you interested when you had some
weirdo uh food we were like i gotta try
not a dog
the dog yeah but you're looking at it
the way you no they don't look at the
dog they don't look at it yeah
apparently
there's a i know a travel writer you act
like we're gonna go home and eat your
dog right now that's how you're acting
he touched my dog
daisy run
don't trust his man with no shirt on i
don't have a craving for any dog but a
vampire
hey do you sicko
i'm not like a former [ __ ] pedophile
around your kids i [ __ ]
got a lot within 50 feet of any dog park
guy can't even walk into
[Laughter]
gerbil oh i had guinea pig in ecuador oh
and i had that that's the dirtiest of
the animals it's so good oh dude it's so
good might as well make cigarettes
guinea pig you ever get a bomb asking
for a cigarette like no and then he
stands there watching and you're like oh
and then you know he just wants to smoke
the end of your butt but you've already
said no so now you gotta smoke it down
to the [ __ ] filter hey sorry yeah
yeah
um yeah that was bad hockey's just
delicious
i should have just give it to him like
i don't have to touch it i don't want
any
yeah i will leave it here
i'll leave it here wait 10 seconds if
i'm walking the streets i'm smoking a
joint i'll pass a homeless guy and i'm
i'm almost done because i know that's
their dream then i'll like i'll walk by
and i'll just like as i go i just like
put it on the ground and let him see me
and then he's like stay stay stay please
now if you'll excuse me my gerbil's
ready yeah i think i did chicago he was
like yeah my gerbil's ready chicago you
had it no no no no no just that joint
where is that oh that smells good i was
like yeah i must have missed that part
yeah
in the mountains of ecuador they have it
and it's so [ __ ] good but they leave
the [ __ ] mouth on you want to insert
a [ __ ] photo i'll show you a photo
oh with the little teeth yeah the teeth
are in there it's like smiling like this
ah oh
they're smiling
happy
yeah they have spit roast them on some
it takes like a while you got to call it
a head sometimes for the really good
restaurants it's like 30 40 bucks too
it's like expensive there that's like
something from star wars man that's
[ __ ] weird it's so good it's a
sustainable ask the dude who [ __ ]
killed himself because that they dated
that actress
who who the guy who killed himself
because because he [ __ ] didn't know
how [ __ ] terrible all actresses are
there's cook guy who went traveling
yeah he he went there and he was like
this is sustainable meat it's it's it's
good for you it's it's so easy to raise
you know how he gets it from church
yeah have you ever had to kill anything
yourself and eat it in your travels yes
only but no just fish yeah me and bobby
kelly caught a fresh one and [ __ ]
pound it immediately fried it up that's
fresh water it was [ __ ] good what
kind of fish trout i don't know who who
who killed it you were bobby bobby he
sliced it open man's he's a man he's a
man could you do that could you slice us
on a fish yeah but getting all the
[ __ ] i'd rather not i'd let a guy do
it plus he's not gonna be around much
longer
don't be a [ __ ] dude
would you kill a gerbil and eat it
and you wouldn't
crush it over the head and uh because
the good thing was i'd already eaten the
gerbil and then we went to um the um
crater line and they have like real
displays about all their cultures from
the amazon to the mountains all the
different indigenous people there and
they have a display about gerbils and
they had gerbils there my dog was like
what the [ __ ]
but like once you see the cuteness of it
i'm like i'm glad i already these yeah
i don't think i can do it they're so
cute
[ __ ] that dude they're responsible for
the black plague eat them all man eat
them all
yeah gerbils really not rats
people had that many gerbils as pets
back then
we're eating them probably right
maybe haggis was delicious that's
another one i went into thinking this is
gonna be shitty but i have to try it it
was so good
late night fried up
that is the thing when you do go
somewhere else and if it's like late
night you got a couple in you and it's
like fried up you're not like there and
like they're hitting they're like oh
this is pigging test it's just like a
chunk of something you gotta have some
hamster it's been deep fried what are
you gonna do
let me get a side of a peanut
[Laughter]
yeah
that's that's typically when i get more
adventurous
yeah what up oh dude so i saw uh i got
indy's team where i saw a guy say this
cool lodge by the whatever
um just traveling on a moped and i
walked by this guy's just looking up in
the woods
and i'm like uh what are you doing
and he goes um hunting parakeets i was
like what
why he goes yeah to eat parakeets i was
like because he had this air gun i was
like no way have you gotten one and he
just lifted up his shirt he had six dead
parakeets
belt yeah
damn
that's
wild it's wild but also like i get if
you're used to it
i don't know was he a local yeah
i mean it was like he was from brooklyn
yeah i'm just shooting these [ __ ]
birds [ __ ] you think i'm doing [ __ ]
i'm hunting toucan
now shut up
[Laughter]
if somebody's serving you like they're
like hey you're on a nice dinner a guest
you're in some foreign place and
thinking 10 seconds and we're serving
you parakeet you're eating it oh yeah
powder i haven't got a problem that's a
bird that's a chicken to me anything i'm
sorry well they serve you monkey
you're eating
i know i listen i know my logic is
flawed in this yeah all animals are
adorable we shouldn't be eating animals
et cetera et cetera but there's just
somewhere i can't do it i eat most
animals i couldn't eat a koala
i couldn't do that
i could do it also i'm saying a birthday
picture or something
like the local like mayor's house and
just a nice dinner and they serve you
all these things like what is that like
and it's that it's koala you're gonna
not eat it in his [ __ ] face what am i
trying to what am i trying to get out of
the mayor am i trying to buy some land
nothing just heard you were traveling
podcasters and patreon people
patreon.com i would say no unless i was
looking for one to play ball with
something you could say no yeah but i
just wouldn't eat it so this is a big
insult to my country it's not to that's
the other thing you want you do want to
please everybody if it's there you're
going to go no thanks that's the main
cause then i'll say i had dog for lunch
all right
that ain't bad i'm all i had about six
hamsters earlier today
[Laughter]
you should try it i had mice for
breakfast i'm sorry sir i don't mean to
insult you
yeah
it depends if i was trying to get him to
buy arms or something like that if i was
doing something something shady for that
yeah yeah if you need something what
about bugs
crickets and chill like they serve that
in mexico all over i had them in uh
columbia in bogota i had ants that's and
they taste like lemon yeah yeah noma i
couldn't eat an and they they right
there they were playing
it's literally like biting into a lemon
like it's like pure lemon zest it's they
were again i was pretty banged up and i
was like is this ants on the steak he's
like yeah and then as a joke they
brought out like a bowl of them and i
just started your wife put them off kind
of [ __ ] joint instance i got a bop i
got a bottle of raid jesus what kind of
raiding you got here i'm gonna um
i'm gonna show you a video then ants are
too cute i couldn't eat an ant
two kids too cute what the [ __ ]
on them in no time
i can't kill 15 ants today on the way
here no i didn't i don't kill bugs at
all that's why when you killed that
spider in chicago i was very upset it
was me or him and i ain't leaving i like
breathing he was a mean looking dude
yeah that's one thing we don't need we
didn't need in the green room there's
this big spider uh i gotta show you guys
the though maybe the worst one
spider
a caterpillar this is also in ecuador
caterpillar
i wrote she ate a roach did you eat a
[ __ ] tarantula did you do a tarantula
dude snake i've seen tarantula in
cambodia
popped open
this is not it but this is um um what's
it called that we caught a piranha
piranha you ain't a piranha see that i
would eat [ __ ] real meta yeah you eating
a piranha and is that true about
piranhas does that really happen if you
fall in yeah they rip you apart yeah in
a swarm uh i don't think so they're not
that aggressive i don't think so i it's
i think that's the movie version of it
yeah they're not on meth yeah they'll
get you t-bone give me a couple of
things over
uh it says in truth it is the piranhas
that are routinely eaten by people
that's crazy you can't eat fish with
teeth like that yeah only if i would
it's like kissing your grandpa
[Laughter]
wait why
i don't know you never kissed your
grandpa they never kissed your grandma
adventures i don't know uh they they
attack a lot of people in the amazon
basin but they don't generally kill them
but they will bite the [ __ ] out of you
yeah they'll jamie up yeah they've
killed like they've killed a handful of
people
so those are
grubs what's a grub rub is like a beetle
larva that's wait the black things on
the stick
what are the black things hanging is
that the coals that's his head
oh they're
alive and they cook them just a little
salt and pepper
i'd have to be oh
that's like a fat caterpillar it's like
a fact
it's like you're eating a disney
character that's [ __ ] up no way dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
i can feel it oh look he's still got his
head sticking out oh you're not [ __ ]
psycho dude
damn dude yeah was it good the first one
was not good but i was like if it had
been on the grill for a bit
this one this is like my medium right
into it too tender and then i had to get
oh so this is how they're just like in
there
oh they just pull them out of like the
trash can oh
that's like larva oh the way they move
they like shoot like liquid you know
what i mean like they like
it's like [ __ ] and then i was like i
gotta try trimmers so i did it in one of
these like other towns what
archer donut where they really pride
themselves on food and it was like this
was good i was like how'd you do a
little salt and pepper a touch of oil
and then just like wriggling and then
they break it faster and then wiggle
slower and stop
oh yeah it's not what you put on it's
what they eat
larva is fed very well yeah one time i
had some shells and cheese on mushrooms
i thought were bugs that kind of freaked
me out
what shells and cheese mac and cheese
oh shells and cheese damn
all right yeah well welcome back to are
you gross
ari is for sure
i think this was still off the laptop
question
um all right let's see this is uh this
is from kiefer
if you're cooking a frozen pizza like
personal size or any size i'm a celeste
so were you talking about digiorno what
are we talking about give me that what
did you do what do you do well the poor
comedy days it was mama celeste
yeah 99 cents yeah how many mosquitoes
do you like on your pizza
what's the grub selection of the key
foods sheriff put your shirt on
okay let's picture mama celeste okay
mama celeste okay uh very trashy by the
way but she's good that was good
poverty-stricken
they're all [ __ ] good man they're all
great they're totino's ones the party
pizzas tottinos pizza rolls of course
yeah bagel bites or pizza rolls why did
i say that weird bagel bites or pizza
rolls
uh yeah pizza rolls back then i get
bigger bites too totino's got me through
poverty yeah that and peanut butter and
jelly and just plain pasta do you have
anything like that in your refrigerator
right now do you have anything like that
no i would never go back to that if i
had i mean you can't what's in your
fridge you can't go that in new york you
can find pizza sure at 4 30 a.m you can
find good pizza so there's no reason for
it back then in l.a what is in your
fridge
um
coffee
some
a fridge leftovers okay all right
nothing so when you're freezing like
something latinos or
some super pretzels you have them
i used to have those corn dogs were
really good those microwavable corn dogs
okay all right
no what
no you're a corn dog
all right now we're separating that was
real hillbilly [ __ ] when i was growing
up corn dogs i don't think i've ever had
that's fair food for sure yeah but i've
never got nothing
you know this guy's eating boogers what
are you talking about
he's eating [ __ ] bugs
i'd be happy to see you think i wish you
the whole thing was corn dogs and i
walked into it uh
for dinner
it's like the temple of doom can we do
an arby's commercial we'll make it aries
and just have all the [ __ ]
aries where's the bugs
we got the ball we got the bucks
[Laughter]
i get her big rams doing them
okay what's so what's your do you have a
frozen pizza now or no no
so you know sometimes they have those
little like kiosks at the bottom of the
hotel they get you through they get they
are that's a pinch man they are deadly
because they got those jimmy dean's
breakfast sandwiches that heat up just
right microwave they got the noodles and
then they got the the thick um soup the
chunky chocolate soup and they got the
pizzas and they got micro pot they got
i'll come back from gorging myself at a
diner and then you pass by like wow let
me just i need snickers or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
gummies i know because you go i'm like
oh i'm gonna need a water for the night
or whatever so you stop and get the
water then you're there and you're like
and you also there's no cash transaction
you're like put it on 403. put it on the
roof from them
i come out if they're not looking i'll
just go
but you're staying there all weekend
what are they gonna do oh man fight me
i think that's where you like you gotta
fight linda the [ __ ] receptionist
all right so how do you cut how would
you cut the the pizza is this the
question yes okay um you take it out god
bless you um
so a lot of them this the question is
rooted in a lot of them come with the
cardboard circle yeah you just put it
well you put it back on that and cut it
and then take your serving so or will
you just put it on a plate cut it and
take the whole thing yourself i remember
being able to afford eventually afford a
pizza cutter
so bad yeah it's they're not that much
but it's you know poverty days just like
you can't you just take a sharp knife
you just cut it and then you cut the
board too yeah you know it'll cut
through
yeah that's how would you ever put it on
a cutting board itself no way yeah
that's crazy i didn't have a cutting
board for the longest time
cutting boards are a pain in the ass to
clean too yeah i do it right now boards
are painted they could seep in or some
of the wooden ones [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] get out of here with that [ __ ]
folks are you having trouble with bug
guts on your cutting board
if you want to see me go back into
poverty come see me sink every dollar i
have into ari shafir jew taping june
12th and 11th and self-produced
self-produced look at that get some
things
[Laughter]
all the cockroaches i can eat
yeah you save money on cockroaches put
that savings right into your specials
would you ever grab a cockroach from
your apartment and pop it in your mouth
and eat it [ __ ] you
you think i live in a place with
cockroaches you're crazy
that's a double insult
double insult toby's got something dude
uh a girl was walking out of my building
today after just
meeting with the with the with the
booker the broker she's walking down the
street and i walked past her and i was
like do not move to that building
there's bed bugs and roaches and it's
the first time i felt like i doled out
new york justice dude wait how'd you
know because i thought bed bugs and
roaches dude nice well it was a while
ago he doesn't have them anymore yeah
yeah that's great you got to tell them
but you can't tell them in front of that
person because then they'll be like
we're raising your rent next time yo
yeah oh i'm moving out and i'm literally
moving out tomorrow oh great
oh yeah don't you have a
any sort of like fantasy of like [ __ ]
over your former buildings like going
there with a picket sign and be like the
the thermostat makes noise in the winter
they won't tell you they won't fix it
yeah former buildings former bosses the
whole nine years yeah they'll raise your
rent 15 percent which is what i'm going
through now these [ __ ] [ __ ] fifteen
more than that i'm like i know but i
live here how long you been in this spot
one year i'm like come on man i live
here you've never run to the site like
rents are sky high right now and i'm
like i can't find my ticket man
just be cool man
somewhere yeah i was wearing tie-dye
also
got some star glasses on
[Laughter]
yeah i had it yeah i never really had
any bad uh
landlords or anything bad bosses or
whatever but i would just end up
quitting those jobs you're like i'm
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] out of here i
remember they had me train somebody at a
restaurant that i was working at like
the last couple days that i was there
and i was like listen man you do what
you want
don't [ __ ] work here you're gonna
hate this place
yeah he told them because you asked them
do they think no you vouch for my
unemployment
well you say they fired me right
i'm going to need numbers dude
that's a different either you're garbage
or you're not is if you go on wanting to
get fired so you get unemployment versus
wanting to be downsized you can get a
recommendation yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i remember i didn't know i was i used to
work at a grocery store in high school
and uh
things are going well
uh just quit two weeks ago
and uh i didn't know i had any great
games i joined the union they make you
join the unit because they're in
philadelphia so it was baggers union
that was
and i was in i was in the one hour photo
department already you had like a no no
show uh paid it well they wanted me to
[ __ ] they went on strike do not touch
that head of lettuce and they were like
what are your hours to pick it i'm like
i got i got a [ __ ] gym class later
today what are you talking about
pick it i'm like you're paying me eight
bucks an hour how do you feel about
marked off cocktails huh the only
picking i know was this nose but i try i
went to i was like i'm gonna get fired
and i was like so i showed up late like
64 days in a row wow and
i was like she's like you've set the
record for consecutive latenesses i'm
like can you just fire me and she goes
you're in the union you're never going
to get [ __ ] [ __ ] me yeah i didn't know
like yeah they can't fire you i'm like
[ __ ]
like there has to go to like a me you
know you have to talk to like the shop
store then he's got to talk to his boss
can you just do it i give i give you
permission i know yeah i'm like please
cause my mom's like you gotta have a job
i'm i was just like i'll get fired
that's the way i have a couple of months
until i find the summer you know what i
mean oh they live off
unemployment it's so great i lived off
unemployment for nine years you know uh
because every time you book commercial
it's like you're paying back in and
they're like i would have done this
every day but they downsized me after
two days
you just keep paying it it's great
oh
1-800-300-5616 what's that the number
for unemployment in los angeles
there's no way that's right but it might
be geez man i weren't you working at the
store or that was under the table
uh that didn't it wasn't they paid for
25 bucks a shift highly illegal pay and
and it was just like that so you make 25
off your 450 a week
but they just tack it on to the last
last seven months this guy's scheming i
think this is the fourth crime he's
admitted to it
and the most important one i mean so far
we have petty theft uh drinking and
driving well there's a limited hey have
you guys ever called this this perfect
statue of limited statute yeah the
statute of limitation here right i i
probably said
i know it's statute but like i probably
in conversation like i say laptop i
probably i also say i say library well
that's trash what about bananer
what no no wha what what no what do you
think it's that most of my family says
banana give me a banana
or a ham or a hamburger i mean if it's
an accent i get it what a ham what
hamburg
hamburger they drop off the er yeah and
they throw it under the banana
these scientists
okay
i wouldn't say it's an accent thing
although the accent is there and it
sounds trashy with the accent it's just
the area upstate pennsylvania near where
where wisecrackers is wilkes-barre is
where my there's no way you've done
wisecrackers never now okay crackers in
the bits and then yeah no no no no no
there's no way i thought at some point
yeah i couldn't get booked to those
places until i was past them okay yeah
this is like this is like a weekend room
ramada in lobby yeah i would have loved
those for forever and then at some point
they reached out i'm like i know i'm not
coming to your place for 300 for the
when you wouldn't have had me yeah but
that's where they get it from upstate
pennsylvania interesting yeah that's the
yinzer area or no that's western that's
western
what's the instead of use like philly
says use like what are you doing
pittsburgh says yins
someone knocking
are you here
would you spot a grub or something what
are you doing no toby looked over there
he caught me oh i was looking at the
cameras oh what are you guys on bye no
what the [ __ ]
this whole thing fell apart in the last
three seconds
let's go with johnny's patreon questions
guys you can submit the patreon
questions at patreon.com
ru garbage consummate pro
um
this is from shawn never had one red is
it garbage to lick the lid of a
condiment if you spill some on it before
putting it back in the fridge well you
lick the nozzle
no you wipe it with your finger like
like a sriracha yeah
like your finger you don't lick the oh
yeah someone else is going to use that
what are you garbage
what about this let's say you have um
something that has an under like a film
thing like a yogurt person like sabra
hummus is a big hummus yogurt those kind
of things
cream cheese oh same top thing that
comes up yeah yeah yeah you lick that
yeah like that but throw it away you do
you so if i you had a thing of cream
cheese all right take the lid off it's
got the foil thing do you rip that all
the way off and throw it out or do you
rip it out just reuse it it's like it's
like your own like uh
it's an extra barrier for the air you do
you leave it but you take it off with a
knife or something
i'll leave it to reseal in a way but but
you take over that our sauber is a good
example take some bread and wipe that
off but you leave that plastic thing on
there yeah sure what are you gonna throw
it away it's an extra chore
yeah i throw away yeah you take it all
the way off because it falls into the
old hummus and then you're like it's
sticky and it rips no you don't you
don't take it off like that you don't
take it off and touch the inside you're
not going
and like [ __ ] pushing it over you
flip it back you got it when you flip it
back it doesn't it's not a hinge on it
yeah
it's got dust and stuff on it you're
saying
it's just gross yeah cause then it falls
into the [ __ ] yogurt or something
like that
do you not see what we're talking about
seeing it i'm seeing it
i'm seeing it this is why you're eating
insects okay
this is a problem
i mean
you're from another planet dude
and the thing with the roach what i
meant was now in those places they farm
those bugs they farm you know they're
they're in the woods but would you if
there was a restaurant in the city that
served new york city roaches or anything
like that it was a michelin restaurant
if it's like you're going a nice
restaurant we have this thing i'm like
that's an experience you go to a
michelin you go to a mission a
three-star michelin michelin restaurant
is that a thing yeah
a mission mission mission
and they're like the special tonight is
subway rat are you gonna try that
[Laughter]
are you going to try that
what else is on the menu is there a
t-bone wait what i've asked is it a
prefix i don't know
would that be a move you would make
a subway rat
i know it's extreme you got to catch
your own too rat i can see rat you ever
read that book king rat
no no actually it's not a great example
i think my michelin star restaurant i
would go this guy is that the best
you know he's the best at what he's
doing on purpose yeah or he lost his
mind a week ago true he knows better
than i do you know what i mean yeah it's
on the menu and if it comes out and you
don't like it put it in the napkin put
it onto the table you're going to like
it he's going to make it right he knows
what he's doing that's the scary part
yeah you're gonna get addicted to it
yeah actually you know you're on the e
train then you're real handsy mold
people going down there trying to get
more rats but i was obsessed with those
people for a while i wanted to see them
so much i've never seen them there's a
really good documentary on them because
they said you could see it from the
train so i'd always be in the very front
so you can see through to the through
the past to the driver
looking for them the whole way and it's
never yeah no the whole network they're
in closed tunnels
so at one point amtrak had a set of
tunnels that they then decommissioned
and they were all living in those
tunnels how many people do you think are
down there realistically a couple
hundred for sure did you ever hear the
rat king they bring that back
a rat king is
all yeah there's their tails all tangled
together and then they start moving in
unison
oh really i don't know that's the that's
the focus i would freak out they
probably just end up eating each other
if you were offered to be able to go
down there and take a tour i'd go you'd
go yeah wow you want to meet him and see
him inside shows
who's out there
you get down there like norman cheers
like
[Laughter]
i got dibs on the grubs
you belong here yeah exactly
we got a whole platter for you
you would eat the grubs but not
i don't want to be rude
will you eat in the bathroom
my own bathroom yes
drink coffee for sure on the toilet why
are you pooping yeah and what's the
what's the regiment when you're pooping
a cup of coffee that's not a regiment
you have an ipad i have a cup of coffee
phones my laptop your laptop you'll see
right there okay sometimes or my phone
and it really is a laptop at that point
any magazines in your bathroom no but i
like those days with magazines it's
better
that's a good chance for your mind to
wander a little bit it's fun yeah you go
through what do you got 45 minutes an
hour it whoa look at it i'm hanging out
at a friend's house and seeing what the
mom has and now a little in style
something like that mm-hmm i saw meme
and showed a can of like bug spray
this is what people did this is what
people read in the toilet oh yeah 100
percent i used to read the back of
shampoo
yeah yeah all the time
i remember reading cereal boxes too when
i was eating my cereal wow yeah it's
just read something yeah you need to you
know something to do better days
a simpler time one would say
all right let's do a couple more then we
got to get mr shafir out of here okay uh
this is from eraser uh first time red
did you do you pers have you ever
personally known a hoarder
you are yeah i fight it constantly what
do you hoard what is your apartment like
i love this picture of something nice
because you got a lady don't you it's
nice now i did an episode of my podcast
alright skeptics tank a long time ago
where me and madiga and tony hinchcliffe
and maybe damadonia i don't know but we
all dehorded my place whoa like what is
this i had a pile and i'm not kidding
the width longer than the width of this
table in a triangle like the pyramids
that we built
[Laughter]
of unopened amazon boxes of [ __ ] that i
had gotten
high online and just like forgot i'm
like why don't but in job and i'm like i
figured i'd open it later and then they
just piled up
years worth wow i just wouldn't throw
stuff out i just wouldn't throw stuff
out i had him unreasonable emotional
attachments to [ __ ]
and then i didn't think anything of it
and then i saw that show hoarders
and i wasn't as bad as that i didn't
have dead cats around
but it was on that line and i was like
oh [ __ ]
was there a smell no okay
and so then i
yeah anything like
like food stuff trail i pick it up okay
um but then it's like i was like i gotta
fix this before i become like those
people so we had a dehording they but
it's something i gotta fight did you
open all those amazon boxes yeah i had
multiples of multiple things so i had
ordered something high i'm like oh i
want that and then i guess six months
later like oh i want that and then got
it again without because i didn't have
it yet right we just did christmas
christmas in july
like how many rhinestone belts can you
yeah and everything i opened i was like
wow this is awesome because like yeah
you ordered it for you man
pastor he's awesome yeah
that guy's great
all these good ideas oh man
just boxes what about you guys i'm bad
with the mail yeah and that's how i look
it's an anxiety thing and once it passes
the first level like unless you have
some mail like oh i gotta respond to
that or it's a bill whatever the next
time you get mail you put it on top that
first one is gone forever now it doesn't
matter because i've let it sit there for
literally a year we just did this
because i was going through looking for
w2s and 109.99s and [ __ ] i went through
a year's worth of mail that i i gotta do
that i gotta look to this nothing
matters i gotta look to that mail unless
they shut it
like
off
you're like oh the power got you all out
yeah i got a business manager because i
was paying so much in late payments and
the credit cards and and the con ed and
all that stuff's like what sir do you
need assistance like financially i'm
like no no i'm actually doing well now
it's just like i'll do it later i'll do
it later
bill pays tough for me i used to do that
for my job i used to pay rich people's
bills oh really and uh like billionaires
and i would forget that they would show
up to their apartments and they'd be
like
the wi-fi is not working i'm like
i had an excuse like ah they were doing
construction in the area the services
might be out i'll call and i would call
them but yeah you owe 400 bucks
and i'm like hey they just sent the
signal try it
they're paying you to do it for them and
you're not even doing it yeah what are
you my boss sorry jesus christ
that's a crippling phobia though
yeah but the male my wife's like you
gotta do something i'm like not today
i'll deal with it it's worse and worse
and worse he's piling up i just throw it
all out at one one time i once said i
had a the tops had those baseball cards
with comedians for a while
and so people
yeah they sal got it first then he
recommended a few people and they
recommend a few people and um
some special edition ones and some
whatever one was from a special they
like do you have anything special and
they add a little circle in the in the
car they put on i put a a shirt that i
wore during a special at the comedy
that's pretty cool
yeah it is but people would send them to
you with a self-adjusting
envelope sounds like a po box before
everybody hated me and then um
uh
so they sent him death threats yeah yeah
yeah
you can close it i don't need it anymore
anthrax um
yeah and so just pile up and one day i
was just like i think before i went to
ecuador i'm like i got it was like a
year and a half's worth and i just like
if you still live at this address here
it is here it is and it just took like
hours and signed and put them back damn
it feels good though it's good
yeah you get through that stuff yeah
yeah it's great
we're learning something here that's one
of the ways that internet addicts you i
just read is that that number of like oh
you have six uh messages or whatever
your your mind wanting to like get order
is like okay i gotta go through those to
get that number gone yeah so then then
it'll pop up for more like okay i gotta
get down there it's like you feel like
you've accomplished something i've kind
of broken that a little bit it gets to a
number where it breaks i used to be the
person of like if it came in i had to do
it i had to do it i had to do it and if
my wife i'm like she'd be like i have 32
unread
emails i'm like that's [ __ ] insane to
me yeah you want to work like even if
it's a [ __ ] just an advertisement
just open it and clear it or delete it
now um
i have multiple accounts well over 20
000 right so then it's okay then i go
yes there's no look at that
because i don't need to if i look at it
i'm like i don't care what the number is
there's a bubble there with a number i
don't correct it's liberated but zero
inbox is like that you've heard of that
people doing that to get to zero like no
messages yeah nuts that's the way i
operated like that for really yeah i
didn't have a lot going on so i wanted
to feel important
[Music]
that's betpath and beyond won't get off
my [ __ ] back send me coupons every
[ __ ] day
send him an email can you hop on a call
real quick
all right we got to wrap up all right
let's boogie june 11th june 12th june
11th is sold out june 12th get some
tickets ari shafir.com in brooklyn go
[ __ ] see him he's the best we love
you love them always love this podcast i
hope you guys uh you know you were one
of the early advocates of us but i will
never forget that never
this is how much wheaty smokes i saw him
right after he mentioned us on rogan i'm
like hey thanks a lot man he goes for
what i'm like
you mentioned us on rogan yesterday he
goes oh yeah i'm like all right what did
i say
yeah all right let's go get a big bowl
of crickets and celebrate we'll see you
next time